to Latin America now we're another year
of serious unrest could lie ahead now in
2019 a wave of protests broke out across
the continent so let's take a look at
some of the countries affected well
Venezuela remains in the grip of an
economic crisis a year ago opposition
leader Juan Guido claimed the presidency
from Nicolas Maduro who's accused of
election fraud and dictatorial rule now
meanwhile Argentina while it is in a
deep recession and unable to pay its
foreign debt or more than one hundred
billion dollars in neighboring Bolivia
President Evo Morales was pushed from
power in November while in Chile and
Colombia protesters are demanding better
governance and solutions to economic
inequality well for more on this now
we're joined by DWS nicole cleric in the
Colombian capital Bogota
good to see you : have you noticed any
similarities in the situations between
various South American countries such as
Colombia such as Chile for example
giving rise to that unrest although at
their core these movements are of course
very different there are significant
similarities these are grassroots
movement started by young people by
students who are fed up of a system that
they inherited from a generation that
was perhaps too scared to speak up for
themselves but is now embracing the
movement they're mostly organizing on
social media and as globalized citizens
they are of course looking at other
countries for inspiration and solidarity
another parallel there is between
especially Chile and Colombia is the
amount of demands that protesters have
this is not a protest movement against a
president a politician a single law this
is against the system here in Colombia
for example demands range from a pension
reform to a full implementation of the
peace agreement with the FARC a better
protection for indigenous people and
many people are also asking for a health
care reform and I talked to some people
here in Bogota to find out why Juan
Manuel loves working at the hospital he
likes to take his time with patients
making sure they feel safe and that
understand their conditions and
treatments but doing the job with such
dedication has become increasingly
difficult for many people working in
Colombian healthcare News una de cada
cuatro
one out of four health care
professionals are unhappy se siente in
feliz una los vecinos
one of our system's shortcomings is the
pay that physicians receive some of them
have to work two or three jobs to make
ends meet but overworked and underpaid
doctors and nurses aren't the only ones
feeling let down by Colombia's health
care system even in the capital Bogota
where there are plenty of hospitals and
clinics patients are finding it
impossible to get even the most urgent
appointments da da da I called the
hospital every day but they don't have
time for me I tell them please I suffer
from multiple sclerosis I need special
treatment
they never have time they give you an
appointment after one or even three
months it's horrible the health care
service here is awful such problems are
related to structural weaknesses
Colombia's health care system is
dominated by private insurance companies
numerous of these intermediaries between
patients and doctors have hit the
headlines for embezzlement and
corruption the president of Bogota
Medical Association says it was their
greed that caused the system to implode
the less services these companies
provide the more money they make so the
insurance company denies treatments all
takes a long time to authorize them
allowing the patient's condition to
deteriorate were they even refused to
cover therapy altogether necessary
treatments denied without explanation it
almost destroyed this young woman's
family her brother had alarming symptoms
but his doctors weren't allowed to run
the tests they needed to diagnose him it
took his insurance companies seven
months to authorize a cat scan from
January until August when they finally
got the results they saw
he had a brain tumor
when we found out he had a tumor he'd
already lost his hearing and suffered
irreversible brain damage
Mariana is a nurse herself and has been
participating in the protests suffering
from the healthcare systems shortcomings
as a patient and a professional she
urges her fellow Colombians to keep
fighting for change I'm confident there
will be change someday maybe not exactly
how we want it to be that would be
perfect and I don't believe that's gonna
happen but some kind of change no matter
how small for the time being it doesn't
look like the government will heed
people's calls but in the waiting room
and on the streets Colombians have run
out of patience straight back over to
our correspondent Nicole scalish there
in Bogota
Nicole people are clearly running out of
patience are there leaders who can
represent them in their struggle well we
have to bear in mind that this is a
protest against the entire political
class so there's not one opposition
figure that could step up and represent
demonstrate and the protesters claims
here in Colombia the strike committee
made up of several unions has been
trying to establish talks with the
government but these have failed over
and over again because the committee
wants these talks to be branded as
negotiations and that is something the
government doesn't want to give in to so
here semantics are getting into the way
of finding a solution and Chile the
situation is different it's a completely
leaderless movement people are
organizing in in groups according to
where they live or where they're their
interests lie what they care most about
but there's not one person or group that
can represent the entire movement some
people say that this is just proof of
how democratic these protests are but it
could ultimately lead to a weakening of
the entire movement
so clearly diverse strands across the
continent but nevertheless what can
people in these countries expect in 2020
it's hard to say seeing the commitment
of people out in the streets it's
difficult to believe that this could
just fizzle out it is still a great
opportunity for embattled leaders like
Sebastian Pinera like even dukkha here
in Colombia to truly listen to the
people to show commitment and honesty
and finding a solution to this and
changed the face of their countries
forever but if the past couple of months
are anything to go by this is very
unlikely to happen
all right I'll correspondent Nicola
foolish monitoring that wave of unrest
for us thanks a lot Nicole good to speak
to you